[Musik]
nun also doch angesichts der
energiekrise in europa will
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
von den grünen zwei süddeutsche
atomkraftwerke nämlich isar 2 und
neckarwestheim noch bis april 2023 in
reserve halten der in auftrag gegebene
stresstest für das drogen system habe
für den winter zwar ergeben dass eine
krise sehr unwahrscheinlich sei sagte
der grünen politiker heute in bonn
allerdings könnten sie auch nicht völlig
ausgeschlossen werden hier ein auszug
seines statements
dann kommen wir zur frage der
atomkraftwerke
und man kann in der situation nicht
ausschließen dass sie bei der
angespannten situation einen beitrag
leisten können die ganzen studien gehen
davon aus dass es bestimmte
voraussetzungen gibt und wir haben in
einem gewissen sinne die schwierige lage
dass wir anfang september eine
entscheidung treffen müssen die
vielleicht im januar oder im februar
ihre konsequenzen nach sich ziehen
deswegen ist die für mich richtige
konsequenz aus dem gesagten aus dem
stresstest dass wir uns diese option
erhalten
nach dem ende der regulären laufzeit der
atomkraftwerke die beiden süddeutschen
atomkraftwerke in eine reserve
überführen so dass sie
wieder genutzt werden können oder weiter
genutzt werden können wenn die situation
ist gebietet und wir uns diese option
nicht entledigen
bei uns im studio als bildpolitik chef
jan schäfer es ist aber auch nicht die
große wende sondern bändchen könnte man
auch sagen richtig ein bändchen man hat
eigentlich wenn man es halt im fußball
sprache beschreibt ein ganz gutes bild
wenn man robert habeck am elfmeterpunkt
sieht und er hat den die möglichkeit ein
tor zu schießen gerade was das thema
strom sicherheit im winter angeht und er
versemmelt diesen schutz er hat ihnen
dann eben genau das ist heute passiert
das ist das was robert habeck in diesen
minuten auch auf einer pressekonferenz
vor trägt der stresstest fast zwei
monate hat es gedauert um zu prüfen wie
wir mit unseren kraftwerken aktuell
durch den winter kommen was ist
möglicherweise auch für bedrohungs 10
marien gibt für die kraftwerk stabilität
also sprich für die frage kriege nicht
genügend strom und auch sicheren strom
und der hat robert habeck entschieden
dass es zwar und so hat das auch gesagt
in seinem statement unsichere
situationen geben kann er aber nur
bereit ist die kernkraftwerke in einen
sogenannten ersatzbetrieb zu stecken das
heißt wenn man absehen kann dass das
stromnetz wackelig wird und es
möglicherweise ein strommangel gibt dann
sollen zwei der drei kernkraftwerke
möglicherweise wieder hoch geschaltet
werden gibt bereits soffin eine ampel
die fdp es damit nicht zufrieden aber
warum ich könnte man mich sagen ja gut
wenn sie gebraucht werden werden sie
sind sie halt da richtig nun wissen wir
dass kernkraftwerke nicht aufschnitt
direkt wie beim elfmeter beispielsweise
wieder hoch geschaltet werden können das
dauert ein bisschen zwischen ein und
drei tagen und die situation im winter
ist manchmal etwas anders da muss man
schnell handeln man könnte umgekehrt ja
auch sagen ja warum laufen die
kernkraftwerke denn nicht länger wenn
wir in einer so großen energie energie
und auch strom krise sind also da gibt
es mit sicherheit noch redebedarf wie
gesagt die fdp findet das gar nicht gut
und ich kann mir nicht ganz vorstellen
dass das genauso geplant wie von robert
habeck geplant jetzt auch ins ziel geht
interessant ist die gute stimmung die
sich die ampel koalition nach ihrem
koalitionsausschuss bis sonntagfrüh ja
eigentlich jetzt erarbeitet hatte durch
ihr drittes entlastungsprogramm die ist
mit dem heutigen abend das muss man
sagen wieder futsch und dahin da gibt es
eher wieder kräftig neuen ärgerten zwei
fragen zum schluss noch kurz warum nur
zwei und nicht alle drei und das andere
ist dass damit beschlossen also kann
habe ich das alleine entscheiden oder
gibts noch eine größere entscheidungs
für zwei in den ersatzbetrieb und nicht
drei eine sehr sehr gute frage nach
allem was wir hören vor allem von seiten
der netzbetreiber handelt es sich
einfach hier um eine politische
entscheidung von robert habeck denn das
dritte kernkraftwerk liegt im emsland in
niedersachsen wo wird aber in wenigen
wochen gewählt in niedersachsen wer
möchte dort an die regierung die grünen
und da ist es also auch selbst aus sicht
von politischen mitbewerbern so dass
robert habeck das ganz gezielt so
gemacht hat auch es traditionell anti
akw genau das ist der präsident von der
spd stefan bayern auch schon gesagt
dieses kernkraftwerk darf auf keiner auf
keinen fall länger am netz bleiben also
da die große kernkraft obi in diesem
land die hat sich da bei robert habeck
auch durchgesetzt bei den arbeiten
kraftwerken wie gesagt dann geht es um
die netzstabilität im süden die frage
war noch kein habe das alleine
entscheiden oder geht das noch irgendwie
durch den bundestag oder was passiert
dann noch also robert habeck hat das
jetzt erstmal so vorgeschlagen und wir
hören wie gesagt von der fdp da gab es
auch den parteivorsitzenden christian
linder schon der das so auf keinen fall
möchte am ende ist sowas immer eine
entscheidung auch innerhalb der ampel
das kann robert habeck nicht alleine
machen da muss es auch die konsens frage
am ende ging es müsste auch wenn es in
ein notbetrieb kommt auch der bundestag
in zweifel noch einmal zustimmen also da
wird es noch viel redebedarf geben ganz
klar ist robert habeck hat mit dieser
aussage wird diese entscheidung heute
erst mal wieder ordentlich feuer in die
ampel gelegt also wenn man auf ruhigere
zeiten gehofft hat dann sind sie mit dem
heutigen abend definitiv vorbei jetzt
zur wende die bild lange gefordert hatte
allerdings in einem substantielleren
ausmaß als es jetzt passiert ist vielen
dank auch
ja und das entlastungspaket von marian
schäfer sprachen und das für gute laune
sorgen sollte wahrscheinlich liegt
seinen beschwingten rausch der zahlen
dass die parteispitzen und der
bundeskanzler so fit und fröhlich wirken
obwohl die 22 stunden verhandelt hatten
65 milliarden euro haben sie in diesen
22 stunden zusammengekratzt sie regnen
sozusagen vom himmel um die bürger zu
entlasten wie immer ist es den kritikern
zu viel den anderen zu wenig aber lassen
wir das mal beiseite und schauen was für
die bürger bürger tatsächlich drin ist
752 euro entlastung für bezieher des
bürgergelds
988 euro entlastung für eine familie mit
zwei kindern und einem jahreseinkommen
von 56.000 euro
855 euro entlastung für rentner in einem
13-seitigen papier hat die ampel
koalition festgehalten wie sie ihre
bürger im kommenden teuer winter
entlasten will rentner studenten und
wohngeldberechtigten bekommen eine
einmalige finanzielle unterstützung
zudem sollen wohngeld das kindergeld
sowie die regelsätze für bedürftige
angehoben werden außerdem sieht das
entlastungspaket steuererleichterungen
vor arbeitnehmerpauschale die steuer
grenze für zusatzzahlungen von
arbeitgebern sowie die pendlerpauschale
sollen angehoben werden zugleich plant
die regierung einen strompreis deckel
für den basis stromverbrauch eine
reduzierung der umsatzsteuer auf gas
sowie den wegfall der eeg umlage es ist
eine echte entlastung in einem
zweistelligen milliarden euro betrag
über den wir hier sprechen also
innerhalb des strommarkt ein
zweistelliger milliarden euro betrag den
wir umverteilen
via twitter verbreitet justizminister
marco buschmann eine genaue auflistung
der zahlen für einen single haushalt mit
einem jährlichen einkommen von
28.800 euro beträgt die steuerliche
entlastung demnach etwa
127 euro jährlich hinzu kommt die
entlastung beim strom in höhe von 140
euro ergibt eine gesamtentlastung von
267 euro pro jahr
am meisten profitieren von dem paket
familien mit zwei kindern und einem
einkommen von 31 1200 euro neben der
steuerlichen entlastung von 534 euro
kommen 740 euro soziale entlastungen und
308 euro entlastung beim strom hinzu
macht zusammen eine entlastung von
1582 euro im jahr
etwas weniger bekommen familien mit zwei
kindern und einem jahreseinkommen von
56.000 euro die steuerliche entlastung
fällt bei diesen familien zwar etwas
höher aus liegt bei 6 180 euro dafür
gibt es mit dieses jahres einkommen
keine sozialen entlastungen rechnet man
die entlastungen beim strom von 308 euro
hinzu beträgt die gesamte entlastung
immerhin noch
988 euro
zudem enthält das entlastungspaket die
verlängerung der folgenden bereits
bestehenden maßnahmen das neun euro
ticket soll einen nachfolger bekommen
der sogenannte spitzenausgleich bei den
strom- und energiesteuern die
sonderregelungen für das
kurzarbeitergeld und die absenkung der
umsatzsteuer für speisen in der
gastronomie auf sieben prozent bleiben
erhalten das dritte entlastungs paket
das wir jetzt geschnürt hat haben ist
von seinem umfang größer als die ersten
beiden zusammen
eine große dimension die wir dort bewegt
haben es geht zum 65 milliarden euro
will nun alles zusammenrechnet
aber die rechnung der bundesregierung
lässt einige fakten unter den tisch
fallen so ist ein kritikpunkt an dem
maßnahmenbündel dass das kindergeld zwar
für die ersten beiden kinder erhöht wird
für alle weiteren aber nicht
um die maßnahmen zu finanzieren will die
koalition auch hohe gewinne von
energieunternehmen abschöpfen scholz
sprach von einer erlös obergrenze für
stromerzeuger die für die
stromproduktion nicht auf das derzeit
sehr teure gas angewiesen sind das wirft
eine große dramatische entlastung seien
auf dem strommarkt und es wird am ende
auch dazu beitragen dass die preise für
strom sind so sieht es also aus dass
laut bundeskanzler möglichst
maßgeschneiderte möglichst effiziente
und möglichst zielgenaue
entlastungspaket oder wie olaf scholz
sonst sagen würde
wir werden niemanden alleine lassen
[Musik]